it's Memorial Day weekend traditionally
the start of beach season in New York
the city has about 22 kilometers of
public shoreline this retired
schoolteachers lived here in what's
known as the Rockaways for 38 years I
don't have a backyard in a front yard I
live in a co-op building this is my yard
this is my outside space this is where I
go for fresh air and socialization and
enjoyment and I want my beaches open but
Rockaway Beach like the rest of the city
and its surrounding communities remain
under strict social distancing
requirements with some of the highest
rates of Kovach 19 in the nation what we
know for sure is we do not want large
numbers of people going on mass transit
right now and that's the only way the
vast majority of New Yorkers are go to
the beach get to the beach here in New
York City the beaches are officially
closed no lifeguards on duty no swimming
allowed walks are fine the mayor says as
long as people maintain social
distancing but he's threatened to take
even that away if people don't comply
yet just beyond city limits many beaches
are open for business
Long Beach is one of several limiting
access to residents David Zellmer has
relieved the beaches are reopening for
his businesses sake but he is weary it's
a tough balance to strike between
keeping you know the community safe
keeping the community access to their
Beach which is a big part of our life
here following the rules is my concern
because if they don't they may have to
close the beaches altogether and I don't
think anybody wants that rules include
wearing a mask near other people and no
contact sports nearby federal beaches
are open to anyone but you need a car to
get there state rules require all
beaches to allow only half as many
people as usual when the city announced
that they won't be opening there was a
fear that is really hard to keep a safe
and healthy beach at 50% capacity with
tens of thousands of people coming out
from the city rain in the forecast may
keep the crowds away for now but warmer
weather is on the horizon with eight
point six million City residents just
over the border kristen salumi al
Jazeera New York